De la ciboulette, du persil et de la menthe.
Ça sent bon.
Et en plus c’est très frais,
on croirait une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Pourtant, je peux vous assurer
que la température a l’intérieur de ma bouche
n’a pas diminué d’un seul petit degré.
En fait, la surface de notre langue
est recouverte de récepteurs
qui se lient aux molécules sapides
contenues dans les aliments,
ce qui leur donnent du goût.
Ça fonctionne un peu comme
un jeu de clés et de serrures.
Il existe aussi des récepteurs sensibles
à la pression, au chaud et au froid.
Si nous avons cette sensation de fraîcheur,
quand on croque une feuille de menthe
ou en buvant une boisson aromatisée à la menthe,
c’est tout simplement parce que le menthol,
le composé chimique contenu dans la plante,
se lie aux mêmes récepteurs
que ceux sensibles au froid.
Le cerveau reçoit la même information
que si nous croquions un glaçon.
En fait, c’est leurre, un trompe-l’œil
ou plutôt un trompe-langue, voire un trompe-cerveau.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celles des jours précédents
en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en publie une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes tous confinés mais on reste en lien.